this is a production of cornell
university yeah
let's get this ball rolling uh thanks
everyone for
for tuning in listening viewing live
audience uh
eighth episode this year the cornell
turf show excited to have
our friend dan shy the director of
grounds here at cornell university
our big red grounds director um so dan
we're going to talk to him
today about some kind of unique things
he's doing around campus uh
things that that we'd like to share with
everybody
but as always we'll start with a little
uh kind of weekly recap
from frank uh as always this morning
carl can you see the screen yeah i can
okay there we go
well this is becoming a popular pastime
these days
people uh bringing flocks of flamingos
they i think people describe it as being
flocked
uh when people come and do this to your
lawn so dan
we gotta give the students the idea to
do this around campus uh
in the meantime um let me highlight
rodney
uh who's still working on this our our
guy uh
moen lawns raisin man uh working now
to um create a more positive image
between uh the community and law
enforcement and of course
this is a volatile and complex issue and
you got to love this guy
running across the country creating
dialogue getting people to
work and talk together and it's and it's
a place where
lawns which usually are divisive can be
a place where we all come together
and i'm always pleased to start at any
time highlighting that
uh but not if you're a mole uh i know we
have a i have a close friend that many
people know dave chinnery one of our
extension faculty
uh in the capitol district has has been
on a personal mission
uh to to eradicate moles from his lawn
and landscape
um this has uh not reared its head as
much as
voles i do hear people talking about it
but this is what it's like when you
harpoon uh or you snap trap a mole
uh it's not a pleasant situation this
was a golf course superintendent in the
midwest uh
just in case you think you're having a
bad day um
another shout out here carl to the
national lawn care folks
uh this april is lawn care month uh and
i think
uh one of the things we are trying to do
here at cornell in our extension program
and certainly at with our
county-based uh faculty in in extension
world uh extension agents like dave and
jennifer
um uh hillary marie
uh victoria in connecticut joellen
everybody who works out
in the field you know we're trying to
make uh what does grass do for us what
role does this
plant system play uh you know in society
if you want to be climate smart
if you want to be water quality uh
conscious if you live around a lake so
you know i think there's ways of
highlighting these things and national
associations are jumping on that all
right
let's get in the weeds uh so to speak uh
just to remind
everybody while i look out at 30 degrees
and snow here in upstate new york i'm
sure dan had to get out of the truck and
looking at salting and you know i don't
think plowing but certainly salting
operations around campus today
uh that can be a topic of conversation
but
it's important to know that we're much
well ahead of normal
you know you look out in buffalo and the
east end of long island throughout the
region
you see that in general uh the growing
season is a week or two
ahead of normal just you know counting
it up over the last several weeks you
can go back further
and it's likely even further ahead of
normal now where it's white
it means that they really haven't
accumulated any base
50 growing degree days right these base
50 growing degree days
are the degree days where we think
biological activity gets going it's
where we measure
the way the growing season gets going
much like we measure
uh growing seasons for vegetables like
between uh frost-free dates
well it's also important to know that
the real story getting out of the gate
is not that it's been warm right and
we've been talking about that forever
with with the way the climate's been
changing
uh but where are we relative to moisture
now if you look over the last month
you can see that throughout much of the
northeast you know
you know once you get north of the
pennsylvania border
it's 25 to 75 percent of normal
precipitation
it's a bit on the dry side now you know
as we say every week wherever
if it's a thursday or friday and
wherever rich buckley is it's likely
raining
and no surprise much of new jersey long
island the metropolitan new york area
southeastern connecticut
orange county had a lot of rainfall
excessive rainfall one two inches or
more in the past week
but in general a lot of the region has
persistently been dry and so you look at
the drought map that came out
on thursday and you can see already
these things that are more longer term
as i've you know learned from my
colleague rt guytano
longer term measures of precipitation
we start to see that again western new
york
western pennsylvania the adirondacks
northern new england
and as usual southeastern new england
you know along
connecticut rhode island you're getting
and still have
drought conditions it's been abnormally
dry
now lest you think we have real dry
weather
i ask you to just put it in perspective
with what our colleagues and
and fellow citizens out west are
experiencing places like
uh nevada colorado utah the governor has
already started to
you know discuss restrictions planning
for restrictions in the state of utah
and relative to lawns and we can get
paige boyle on later in the
in the in the in the turf show as the
weeks go on
to talk about the way they have to water
out there to provide that turf
because should we get into a dry
condition we're going to want to
understand that a little bit better and
where
where better to do it than out west now
as we move into
sort of where we are in the season i
think the
thing that gets everybody's attention
early on is the generally how
quick is the grass greening up do i have
to mow it yet
and what weeds are growing well if
you're looking at weeds now
that are really actively growing uh
things like annual bluegrass
uh hen bit in this case this is a
picture of purple dead nettle right
henbit that is starting to grow probably
you'll see seedlings of some perennials
now um
if you're gonna do some broadleaf
post-emergent broadleaf weed control to
these populations of plants
you want to get them pretty quickly now
i would recommend
spot treating them in places if you felt
like you had to do it if they were
really disrupting
the quality of the site but once they
get into warm weather and flowering
they're going to die
right they're going to die so if you if
these are objectionable now
you might want to do some spot treating
and then get some seed in the ground
right get
get some grass growing uh and and maybe
even
a fertilizer shop but we'll talk about
that all right
here's the progression of soil
temperatures and you can see not very
much
it's a little bit warmer you're starting
to see
a little bit more into the 50s now but
most into the high
40s uh and and you got to get down to
south jersey
into the delmarva uh till you get into
the
50s on a regular basis and yesterday in
the podcast uh
in the in the show with uh uh john
ingrajado
at connecticut we talked about you know
it's not just a blip it's like
how soil is something that warms over
time or you know
getting warm and staying warm is is how
uh
biological organisms evolve and persist
through the year
uh so so just uh you know temperature
fluctuations here or there the story
here is you know it's barely getting
into the 50s in most places
now usually what happens again uh what
we think about is i got to get my weed
and feed out i got to get my weed and
feed that has pre-emergent crabgrass
control in it
and so when you have uh that mindset
to get your pres down you can see that
the green is
the ideal time uh for pre-emergent
applications and we are
really in that ideal time throughout
much of the northeast
with just a little bit on the early side
and and again on the later side but
still okay
uh you know down into delmarva so you
certainly have a couple of weeks yet
now what does this relate to well you
know obviously if you're
looking at pre-emergent crabgrass
control in a lawn care setting
you know you're trying to tie it into
when the crabgrass germinates
and get that barrier down and active
before it germinates now if you're a
lawn care operator that's trying to
spray 3000 lawns as we talk about
oftentimes
it's going to take you a while to get
that done and so consequently
you try to get it down early now one of
the things you have to understand is if
the germination is not going to happen
for a few weeks which i think
we can say with some confidence it's not
going to happen for a few weeks
you get that pre-emergent down and then
it's going to wear out
while seedlings are still emerging later
in the season or break down
more rapidly now this is going to be
slowed
and changed based on soil conditions if
it's really dry
it's probably not going to break down
very much and also if it's really dry
not a lot of weeds are going to be
germinating so you know you want to keep
these things
uh in mind as you think about timing and
persistence of these herbicide
applications that you make so
we use the old-fashioned phenological
indicators you know
generally around forsythia bloom full
bloom
is where you start to see uh some early
germinates and open
areas of crabgrass but we're still a
little ways from that
and it's important to understand when
you look at how crabgrass emerges
that it emerges slowly over a long
period of time it's not necessarily
something that happens all at once and
so having that barrier coinciding
with the germination in a you know where
crabgrass is a big problem for you
is important to use that chemical as as
wisely as possible
now the other thing i think of course
we're thinking about in the springtime
is fertilization
and i'll just draw your attention again
as we start to think about these things
uh particularly when they have water
quality concerns and more and more
people are going to be concerned about
that
as they should be and especially in the
lawn and grounds area where you got a
lot of grass
a budding or right next to pavement you
want to be really mindful when you put
something down if it spills there you
got to clean it up
you don't want to get it you don't want
to get it into the drain you want to
make sure it gets into the canopy so it
can't run off with a heavy rainfall
right into a sewer
so you know these areas are very high
risk when we don't actually think about
it much like that
and so in this publication i'll draw
your attention to
how they recommend fertilizing now for
example if you go in
and you fertilize just once a year right
one of the things that's really
important is you just don't see
a lot of people recommending early
spring fertilizer
maybe you fertilize twice a year they
want you to get it on a little bit early
greater than 50 at slow release and
less than nine tenths of a pound of
total nitrogen so again
in non-sensitive areas right areas where
there maybe isn't surface water
maybe where you don't have to worry
about spilling it on the pavement
if you're making two applications
obviously when you get to three and four
applications
uh you can see that the nitrogen gets
spread out over the course of the year
so if you're putting it down four times
this is saying you're putting on about
three and a quarter pounds
uh uh four times three and a quarter
pounds of nitrogen
uh at least half of it has slow release
right you get to one uh two
applications a year you're about you
know 1.8
right if you're making two fertilizer
applications a year now there's a
totally different mindset if you're
thinking about environmentally sensitive
areas
right if you're thinking about near
where you have water quality issues
where you have
lakes where you have pavement where
their
wrist gets a little bit higher right
next to the pavement right next to the
lake right no surprise here
so you notice again not much fertilizer
recommended in the early part of the
year
and certainly no fertilizer ever
recommended
during summer months right when nitrogen
is probably coming free from the soil
anyway
so really important to remind yourself
that's a very easy publication to get
your hands on
it's available online i think we connect
to it on our website if we not if we
don't
uh carl we'll be sure to put that link
up now as i welcome my pal here
uh let me introduce him a little bit i
got a couple of things to set them up
for our discussion today
and first is you know of course you know
i'm going to embarrass him i told him i
was going to do it
when we were finishing our beverages on
on wednesday evening
you know professional grounds management
professional lawn care right
professional golf course superintendents
professional
sports turf managers when you you know
get paid to do this at the highest level
there's an expectation
that not only are you know the technical
stuff and there's an assumption that you
can navigate your way through that
but that you can lead and that you can
you know have a plan
for what you're going to do and you have
an operation that has processes
and maybe even standards if you're lucky
right and so dan of course has this
great website he maintains here
uh and in that website it articulates a
little bit about
core level surfaces feedback surfaces
uh services that he offers uh
quite a bit you know obviously dan's
talking about how much lawn he's
maintaining
there's obviously a complex landscape of
trees and shrubs
you know 40 miles of storm and sanitary
sewers
you know lawn areas that are damaged by
construction all this stuff costs a
little bit
more to maintain but again you know the
key here i'm trying to highlight
is you look at lawns and you look
at it in the grounds operation and
operationally when you're a professional
it's important to have that broad view
now of course dan's big initiative that
he had at the university of rochester
and
obviously brought here with us over the
years
has been this tall grass less gas
initiative where
we had started to do some of this around
campus prior to his arrival
but obviously when he came here he
really embraced it
and has promoted these areas and i can
tell you there simply isn't a higher
profile area on the cornell campus
than here on live slope and of course as
you look across some of these natural
areas right on live
slope in and amongst the oaks on live
slope
you see these wonderful vistas that
people take pictures of
post win us awards but he's also done
this in other
areas on campus so as we translate this
you know into a lawn landscape right how
does this is
how is this gonna look in a lawn is
anybody actually gonna
like this if we put this into a lawn
landscape
is there is there a value to this in the
lawn landscape and so
i draw your attention to uh some uh
thinking that's going on at the
university of minnesota that we've
certainly highlighted in the past
and i know dan uh gets involved in here
is is imagining lawns as having
different management levels and nothing
none of these systems are no management
right even rain gardens none of these
systems are no
management there's some level of
management but as a turf grass manager
sometimes we never really think much
beyond
just the traditional turf and i think
we're seeing particularly in you know
progressive environments like a place
like cornell
interested in expanding our
understanding
of to address the spectrum
of ways you can use these vegetated
surfaces in the landscape
and of course communicating that dan's
got the signs and you wouldn't believe
i'm on this campus every day dan
and i actually don't have a picture of
these signs
uh that you use on campus but i know my
colleague
our colleague jennifer lerner down in
putnam county
has done a lot with developing these
pollinator gardens and
creating a pollinator pathway system and
i believe the cornell campus is becoming
part of this
pollinator pathway and it's really just
a way of imagining
managing the lawn and the landscape in a
way that has services so dan
i'm going to welcome you to the show
thanks for being patient while i ranted
for the past 15 minutes
and i have a couple of questions up here
that i'll leave up there
uh for now i want to look at you on the
side so you can see them there
and so this is uh what i wanted to chat
with you about today again
not just the technical stuff like i
introduced earlier but
also the mindset that you approach the
management of the lawns
uh on this cornell campus you know
what's evolved right you know i
i hate to break it to you you did retire
from one place and
and now you're at this place um i wonder
how you've seen this evolve at two
institutions
you know how long is viewed by your
customers
and how it's maintained by you and the
adaptations you might have made
over the years so welcome to the show
dan good to see you
um how do you want to approach this
really big question
well it's it's interesting frank so i
came to cornell
and of course you're here and so there's
a lot of practices the campus being this
living laboratory there's stuff that
that happens here that
happens here sooner than maybe many
other places
so um i came from a campus at university
of rochester where
you know we mowed it two and a half
inches we
ran the wheat eater along the edges of
the sidewalks and we keep this nice
you know more manicured
uh look to the to the canvas and came
here and
at your guidance over over the years and
the acceptance and the professionalism
of the staff here they picked up
and started mowing the lawns at three
and a half inches
um which as you can imagine
um has all the benefits that you talk
about right deeper root system
less weed invasion i mean all the all
the things that you promote
were already in place when they came and
i have to tell you my first
look at the campus was oh that looks
different and now
i it didn't only took me a couple weeks
and i love it because you can tell the
difference between a
two and a half inch lawn and three and a
half inch long
and now i can't even tell the difference
anymore and
a lot of the lawns here on campus have
been seated over
seeded or satted with uh tall fescue uh
turf type top fescues again at your
recommendation for all the reasons that
you recommend this you know drought
tolerance
and and all and wearability and all the
various things so
a lot of things were in place and so the
difference is i came from a campus that
was
you know more maintained on a
on a more um on a schedule of
you know week control and all that to a
campus that says hey we're a sustainable
campus
right we're not going to just uh we're
going to try to manage things as best we
can
with fewer inputs and one of the
probably the easiest thing you do is
raise your mower
right off the bat and so that was
already in place
and i think a lot of those things work
for us
and so in addition to raising the mowing
height
we completely eliminated or reduced
mowing in a number of areas that you've
really moved to
and that also has its sort of ooh
that looks different that has its own
sort of ooh that looks different there
you go thanks for doing that dan really
appreciate that
so so people say oh that looks different
and um talk a little bit about how
this started and has evolved
well i think if you're going to do
something different frank right you have
to tell people what you're doing
because if you drove by this this is at
the main intersection on
campus it's a slope that was a little
hazardous to mull it was probably just a
little over the
the degrees that you would want to mow
um
and uh if we just didn't mow it it
looked like our lawn mower broke down or
we were lazy or we didn't know what
we're doing so i think it's important
like you have with that pollinator
garden you know
to some people might look well how come
they're not doing anything here's all
these
wildflowers why they have goldenrod here
and all this kind of stuff so you
educate folks and we're an educational
institution
so in conjunction with our um
sustainability division that says
you know cornell's going to be carbon
neutral by 2035
i work with them i talk with them they
help develop a prototype for this sign
for me which also says underneath it
if you get up close you know helping
cornell achieve its goal of carbon
neutrality by 2035. so we're telling
people what we're doing
and i probably could add to this you
know we're creating pollinator habitat
as well i probably could modify
the sign and go to the next level with
it so in addition say in an addition
creating pollinator habitat which i may
do in the next rendition of science
well and since you brought it up dan um
there's two other components that i want
to talk about one is
obviously the mowing's evolved and
before we get
to the pollinator stuff let's talk for a
second about the way you think
uh nutrient management fertilization and
weed control might have evolved
uh in the way you're too you've done it
at the two institutions
well at both institutions and even here
we scout and we only
treat the worst areas um high profile
and worst areas
so that was in place before i got here
in fact here they have
more wonderful maps than i had at
rochester i just had a campus map and
i'd highlight and
throw the square footage in for the
company that came in to do the treatment
for us because we
we were just too s too taxed with other
work to actually get out
and and and and get the the wheat
control done at the right time
the challenges you have on a on a
college campus are fit and
fitting your um work around the students
right you don't want to be out there and
shutting down a portion of the campus
for 24 48 hours
and the students can't use it and let
alone the phone calls you might get from
concerned parents so
we try to we just had that discussion
today
uh we got a crabgrass problem on the art
squad
and i was talking to kevin about it said
well you know you think we can get
something in it was pretty isolated we
can identify the areas and
just get a straight pre-emergent control
no fertilizer
so we don't have to worry if an area we
know didn't have it we won't have
striping or different colors
so we're talking about he goes what you
know they're going to have
cornell wellness days out there for the
students and they're going to have
movies starting on the art squad in
another couple weeks they're going to
have movies out there
so then the discussion obviously changed
from while do we go from pre-emergent to
post-emergent once the students leave
you know so we're having those are the
kind of conversations you have here that
you might not have
um in a a commercial site well but at
the same time dan
you know i can tell you there's not a
person in his who works in his business
all the time
that doesn't appreciate the out of sight
out of mind
phrase right i mean we you know i think
it's
it's it you know people use pesticides
even in places where they're highly
restricted
they use them at central park under a
very controlled
way they use them here in a very
controlled way in a targeted way
not so much maybe in the past it was
more of a blanketed approach
where you know everything got a
pre-emergent everything got some
fertilizer
everything got a broadleaf application
especially before graduation
and whether you're in the home lawn
market or the golf course market you
know
you know you want to sort of stay a
little bit out of people's minds
especially in the lawn care industry
where you know blowers have to get
involved to make sure you're cleaning
the pavement
and stuff like that so i think it's one
thing you know you've obviously
been able to continue that practice of
having strategic
chemical use but the growing
interest in this pollinator enhancement
in the aspect of the landscape is is
gonna at some point likely gonna bring
up some discussion
further beyond exposure to students in
general
you know how much are you using these
other things and i would say other as
really any other pesticide any pesticide
when you're now concerned about being
part of the pollinator pathway so
how do you see that conversation uh
evolving
uh over the next several years as all of
us start to see
how big of a deal this conversation is
going to be in the lawn and landscape
area
well i think the uh the b lawn right
which is just coming to
coming to a campus near you we've got a
group of
students that want to get involved in
the uh b-lawn area
you know i think um if like anything
it'll have to be
a mindset um like anything with you know
we
you and i have talked about the term
maintenance and management right
maintenance is upkeep just continual
repair you just go out and you do it
management is you look at it and you
establish like you do with ipm for pests
you do the same thing with weeds what's
your threshold
what can you tolerate in a certain area
and i think our threshold
for weeds will uh increase
that we'll you know we'll go from two
dandelions per acre
um that and you got to go out and treat
down to you know
four dandelions per square foot or
something i mean i don't know you know i
throw those out there but at some point
you're gonna there the threshold
and your tolerance will increase i do
see that happening and that's already
happening here at cornell we we don't
get
um since i've been here and we've we've
reduced the lawns were
prior to my coming had been let go a
little bit according to to kevin and he
got him back in shape and you know with
a pretty rigorous program and we've been
able to scale back from that now because
of
the work he did to get things under
control and now target our approach
i don't know if we'll do away with it
completely but i do see more and more
reductions coming i think that's
i think we might see that i don't know
if we're going to see that in the
residential
landscape you and i have talked about it
people still want that green post
stamp in front of their house but you
know you look at what's happening in
minnesota where they're giving out
grants they get about 900 000
worth of grants for people to turn their
lawns into be habitat
um so well yeah money but yeah i think
you're right i think when people start
putting their money where their mouth is
uh i think there is going to be like you
said an evolving uh
aesthetic but there's one thing that
isn't evolving dennis we're getting
close to the
to the wrap up here i want to see if
there's any questions but i got to ask
you with snow on the ground outside
this is when i worry the most about
a sidewalk turf that you're still
gonna put some salt out there today and
that grass is broke dormancy it's a hell
of a lot greener today than it was just
a week ago
you know we've had pretty consistently
warm temperatures
uh or even if not warm sunny
and sunny heats the pavement breaks the
dormancy of the plants next to it
you don't have graduation uh this year i
don't think or maybe i don't know about
in-person stuff but
we still got dead grass along the
sidewalk did you make a decision today
to try to mitigate that damage
or do you just now get into repair zone
and how do you manage that stuff right
along the edge of the sidewalk now
we're gonna have to repair uh we can't
we can't
uh the liability of not doing anything
um
is uh you know is just we just can't
have that what about safer salts uh if
you can afford them
you know i got 61 miles of sidewalk and
15 miles of the road so
um you know if now what we have gotten
is better metering on our equipment and
i had a
chat with all of our staff before this
snow so temperatures are going to be
warmer
we don't need as much product out so
close the gates down
slow things down a little bit we don't
need to put as much out because there's
there's an incredible relationship
between how salt works i mean between 30
and 25 degrees salt loses two-thirds of
its
capability at 30 degrees a pound of salt
melts 45 pounds of
ice and at 25 degrees it only amounts
15. so i mean
the exponential temperature but so the
other morning when it was snowing out it
was 34 degrees
you know we can i mean it was almost
melting without salt so
we had was the refreeze last night when
it got cold so
see this is we're getting we're getting
close down but this is why we got to
have you back this salt conversation is
a conversation
in my mind uh of its own i mean we have
probably operations in new york state
where most of their
revenue comes from uh managing salt in
the in the lawn and landscape business
if they're doing some plowing
but listen carl what about questions
what about questions
how are we doing we're getting close
yeah so so ben
polymer has a good question he's asking
about dan what are some of your
communication strategies and deal
in dealing with for example students or
employees who are concerned about
pesticide use i know we talked about the
long grass less gas
signs uh have you had any strategies
dealing with with the
community stakeholders in terms of
pesticide use yeah i i will tell you
since i've been here i've probably only
had three phone calls
um in the five uh growing seasons i've
been here
relating to that from a parent
and a lot of it was discussing kind of
what we used
you know sharing with them um you know
that
products have things called ld50s and
everything you know just having a
conversation a little bit about the
science of it without without trying to
to to um justify it
yeah to just say that you know we we use
the safest products we we can use
and here's why and here's the reason why
we're using why do you use
we control well some kids have b
allergies and we want to be mindful of
that that's one of the
issues with the tall grass we got issues
with rodents and ticks and other things
that can come
in those tall grass areas so it's not as
simple as just well just do it but you
everything you do has some other con
side
um sidebar some other so so i guess dan
i would say the answer to ben's question
is try to be as transparent as you can
when they call you but i don't i mean
other than the signs
i think there is this out of sight out
of mind you try to stay
you know minimizing their exposure to it
uh
using products that are targeted uh
no not not doing it when they're around
or likely to encounter it all
of these things are critical aspects to
i think talking about the mindset
you have that it is in a blanketed
approach
right it isn't a blanket i think your
point timing is important so
we missed the spring week control window
because of commencement and reunion and
all that stuff so we've
gone to october as our next best so we
do our
our week control application the fall
when students are on fall break
so they leave campus we do the
application um
generally the signs can be removed
before they come back or if they're
still there it doesn't matter we're not
trying to hide anything from them
they can last but we we don't we try not
to do it when
when there's a high student population
and that's a challenge
yeah and that's a great question that
can be a topic of many conversations
when you get a bunch of professional
land managers around so carl
dan let me thank you in advance uh
thanks again i'll look forward to our
next beverage
uh soon i hope and uh carl uh
take us out of here yeah uh thanks
everyone episode 8 of the cornell turf
show in the books
uh again thanks to dan shy frank rossi
for for stewarding us through this
episode uh we'll see you guys next week
hopefully we're going to talk about some
more
infield skin stuff next week and some
ways to quantify that that'll be pretty
cool for our friday
uh webinar next week opening day it's
opening day man baseball is underway
baby i sat and watched four innings
yesterday
damn yankees you know you can't win
scoring two runs brothers you know we
didn't pay all that money to get two
runs
that's all i got to say about that yeah
so we'll see we'll check back in with
everybody next week hopefully the yanks
have won a couple more for our yeah
uh thanks everyone for joining we'll see
you guys next week
thanks dan this has been a production of
cornell university
on the web at cornell.edu